[Applause]
[Applause]
I would say good morning but it's
afternoon I'm grateful to Vanessa and
Bryan family for the opportunity to
speak today I'm grateful to be here
Jonna Gigi and celebrate the gift that
Kobe gave us all what he had come
that's the basketball player as a
businessman and a storyteller and as a
father in the game of basketball in life
as a parent Kobe left nothing in the
tank he left it all on the floor
[Applause]
maybe it's spies people that Kobe and I
are were very close friends but we were
very close friends
khob reasons my dear friend he was like
a little brother
everyone always wanted to talk about the
comparisons between he and I I just
wanted to talk about Kobe you know all
of us have brothers and sisters
little brothers little sisters who for
whatever reason I always tend to get in
your stuff your closet your shoes
everything it was a nuisance if I could
say that word but that nuisance turn
into love over a period of time just
because the admiration that they had for
you as big brothers big sisters the
questions they're wanting to know every
little detail about life that they were
about to embark on he used to call me
text me 11:30
2:30 3 o'clock in the morning talking
about post up moves footwork and
sometimes the triangle
at first it was an aggravation
but it then it turned into a certain
passion this kid had passion like you
would never know and so it's amazing
thing about passing if you love
something if you have a strong passion
for something you would go to the
extreme try to try to understand or try
to get it either ice cream colas
hamburgers whatever you have a love for
you've got to walk you would go get it
if you have to beg someone you would go
get it what Kobe Bryant was to me was
the inspiration that someone truly cared
about the way I either play the game or
the way that he wanted to play the game
he wanted to be the best basketball
player that he could be and as I got to
know him I wanted to be the best big
brother that I could be
[Applause]
to do that you had to put up with the
aggravation the late-night calls or the
dumb questions I took great pride as I
got to know Kobe Bryant that he was just
trying to be a better person a better
basketball player we talked about
business we talked about Finley we
talked about everything and he was just
trying to be a better person
now he's got me I'll have to look at
another crime mean for the mix
[Applause]
I told my wife I wasn't gonna do this
because I didn't want to see that for
the next three or four years that is
what Kobe Bryant does to me I'm pretty
sure of Vanessa and his friends all can
say the same thing he knows how to get
to you in a way that affects you
personally even though if he's being a
pain in the ass but it she always ever
has sense of love for him and the way
that he can bring out the best in you
and he did that for me I remember maybe
a couple of months ago he sends me a
text and he's saying I'm trying to teach
my daughter some moves and I don't know
what I was thinking or what I was
working on but what would you what were
you thinking about when you were trying
to as you've grown up trying to work on
your moves I say what age he says 12
I said 12 I was trying to play baseball
he sends me a text back saying laughing
my ass off
and this is at two o'clock in the
morning but the thing about him was we
could talk about anything that related
to basketball but we can talk about
anything that related to life and we as
we grow up in life really have friends
that we can have conversations like that
well it's even rare where you can go up
against adversaries and have
conversations like that I went and saw
Phil Jackson in 1999 or maybe mm I don't
know when Phil was here in LA and I walk
in and Kobe is sitting there and the
first thing I'm in a soup
first thing Kobe said did you bring your
shoes
no I wasn't thinking about playing
but his attitude to compete and play
against someone he felt like he could
enhance and improve his game Jimmy
that's what I loved about the kid
absolutely loved about the kid no matter
where he saw me it was a challenge and I
admired him because his passion you
rarely see someone who's looking and
trying to improve each and every day not
just in sports but as a parent as a
husband I am inspired about what he's
done and what he shared with Vanessa and
what he's shared with his kids I have a
daughter who is 30 who just became a
grandparent and I have two twins I have
twins at six
[Applause]
I can't wait to get home to become a
girl dad and to hug them and the see the
love that didn't the smiles that they
bring to us as parents he taught me that
just by looking at this tonight looking
at how he responded and reacted with the
people they actually loved these are the
things that we will continue to learn
from Kobe Bryant to Vanessa
Natalia Bianca Capri my wife and I will
keep you closer in our hearts in our
prayers we will always be here for you
always I also want to offer our
condolences and support to all the
families affected by this enormous
tragedy Kobe gave every last ounce of
himself to whatever he was doing after
basketball he showed a creative side to
himself that I didn't think any of us
knew he had in retirement he seemed so
happy he found new passions and he
continued to give back as a coach in his
community more importantly he was
amazing dad amazing husband who
dedicated himself to his family and who
loved his daughters with all his heart
Kobe never left anything on the court
and I think that's what he would want
for us to do no one knows how much time
we have that's why we must live in the
moment we must enjoy the moment we must
reach and see and spend as much time as
we can with our families and friends and
the people that we absolutely love to
live in the moment means to enjoy each
and every one that we come in contact
with
when Kobe garnet died a piece of me died
and as I look in this arena and across
the globe a piece of you died or else
you wouldn't be here the rules are the
memories that we have to live with and
we learn from I promise you from this
day forward I will live with the
memories of knowing that I had a little
brother that I tried to help and
everywhere I could please rest in peace
[Applause]
you